[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec kristen croisière
suivez bien je compte de danse sur glace
grand moment est arrivé
axel des tirades j'ai utilisé vision
sensationnel il reste 45 secondes et
tous les espoirs désormais son père dit
c'est parfait ce soir c'est le bonheur
dont la france nathalie péchalat et
fabian bourzat rendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très impressionnant bonsoir à tous j'ai
pas l'habitude d'être devant un public
sans vous êtes dans mon élément naturel
la glace avec mes petits patins aux
pieds mon partenaire à mes côtés et même
un petit costume à paillettes ça me
manque j'ai pas mon coach non plus j'ai
pas mon chorégraphe dans les coulisses
en même temps on est d'accord que ça
n'aurait vraiment aucun sens mais pour
préparer ces deux soirées j'ai fait
appel à un membre de mon équipe
quelqu'un qui a une image un petit peu
noir un petit peu plombante même voire
négative et c'est pour cette raison que
je vais demander de rester ce soir dans
les loges c'est quelqu'un que je
connaissais absolument pas quand j'étais
enfant ni à 7 ans quand j'ai commencé le
patinage en sport études ni à 12 ans
quand j'ai quitté ma famille pour
rejoindre un pôle france et donc
intensifier mes entraînements pour
préparer mes premières compétitions
internationales il est en prêt dans ma
vie j'étais ado il intervenait quand bon
lui semble et pour moi évidemment
s'était jamais le bon moment
il était un petit peu vous savez comme
le pétrole ou le pote bourré qui squatte
chez vous jusqu'à 4 heures du mat et qui
vous répète sans cesse la même chose et
vous n'avez qu'une envie c'est qu'ils se
taisent et plus je m'étais l'enjeu dans
ma vie de sportif de haut niveau est
plus prenez place il a pas un nom facile
à porter je pense que vous avez tous
affaire à lui c'est monsieur doute alors
pour comprendre le rôle qu'il a joué
dans ma vie je vais vous partagez j'ai
partagé une année sportive la saison
2010-2011 à l'été 2010 avec mon
partenaire fabien on était à moscou
depuis trois ans et expatriés pour
s'entraîner avec un coach russe et les
débuts je vais pas vous le cacher on
était très compliqué pour moi vu que je
ne parlais pas la langue
je connaissais pratiquement personne je
vivais avec mon partenaire dans neuf
mètres carrés alors qu'on n'était pas du
tout ensemble dans la vie et on n'avait
pas de connexion internet donc pas de
skype
mais le truc qu'on avait c'était un
objectif commun on voulait devenir
champion d'europe en patinage
il faut qu'on monte de nouveau programme
chaque année alors ça c'était vraiment
le kiff avec fabian parce que ce qu'on
aimait nous c'est et raconter des
histoires interpréter les personnages
changent et pau tous les ans donc on
passait de
des rolling stones aux petits princes
docteur jivago 4 la momie et son pharaon
et on essayé d'être le plus audacieux
possible quand on veut être audacieux
pas forcément il faut prendre des
risques quand on prend des risques on a
des doutes des doutes à répétition mais
qui vont nous servir à bâtir un projet
qui va être cohérent et sincère alors
d'abord monsieur doute il est là sur
toute la partie artistique un canton
brainstorm sur les thèmes quand on se
demande si on va patiner sur telle ou
telle musique travailler avec tel ou tel
chorégraphe il est présent il est
présent aussi sur toute la partie
technique
quand on va créer des nouveaux portés 30
fabian arrive avec des idées farfelues
et quand on est obligé de faire des
croquis et de trouver une solution pour
que tous à 7 yens sur 2 mm de large
c'est exactement la dimension de nos
lames mais monsieur d'outils l'important
dans ce cas de figure parce qu'il nous
aide à nous protéger du danger
et puis monsieur doute il est là
évidemment sur toute la partie
stratégique quand on va sélectionner des
éléments techniques
incorporé dans nos programmes parce que
le patinage c'est pas simplement un art
c'est aussi et surtout un sport et on
doit scorer
chez nous il n'y a pas de temps à battre
y'a rien à mesurer ce qu'il nous faut
c'est convaincre un jury surprend le
public est chaque année se réinventer
tout allait bien on était confiant
puisque on avait réussi à dissiper le
doute à chaque étape on était prêt pour
se lancer dans cette saison il nous
restait six semaines de préparation et
la fédération française comme à son
habitude a envoyé un juge à moscou pour
qu'ils puissent valider nos programmes
et là c'est la catastrophe parce qu'il
nous dit que le programme est décousu
c'est à dire qu'il est absolument pas
convaincu de l'assemblage de la musique
donc pour nous c'est c'est juste une
énorme angoisse qui vient frapper à la
porte à ce moment là monsieur doute
alors un monsieur doute gonflé à bloc un
rouge colère sauf qu'avec fabien on en
est conscient la phase de modification
elle est terminée au contraire
maintenant faut automatiser les
mouvements faut les répéter plusieurs
heures par jour pendant un mois
ça va être une petite confrontation il
va essayer de rentrer je vais lui
claquer la porte au nez il va passer par
la fenêtre il va me un bordel
monstre
et sur la glace avec fabian on va
dévaloriser notre travail perdre en
confiance et s'engueuler et c'est vrai
qu'il fallait pas trop nous pousser on
était plutôt bon pour ça au bout du
compte on a que deux solutions soit on
continue de lutter contre monsieur doute
et ne pas essayer ce qu'il a envie d'une
part entendre qu'il envie de nous dire
et ça ne fait qu'envenimer la situation
ou alors eh ben on décide de laisser
rentrer et le mettre dans le canapé
confortablement installés et puis on a
une conversation et nous a dit mais les
gars s'il ya un mec un juge en
l'occurrence cas cette hésitation saute
programme peut y en avoir dix huit peut
même bien avoir dix-huit mille ce que
monsieur tout à fait à ce moment là
c'est qu'il nous a permis d'accepter ce
que le juge nous a dit de façon très
brutale et je me suis rendu compte à
quel point en accepter mais en toute
confiance les honneurs les bons
résultats et par contre ont rejeté
complètement toutes les réticences ou
tous les résultats qui ne sont pas
favorables
donc fort de ça on a voulu revoir
l'intégralité de nos programmes et
proposer quelque chose de différent
on a modifié le thème l'histoire les
personnages et le pari était très
risquée puisque on avait un timing
vraiment très serré mais ça a payé
puisqu'on a gagné tous nos grands prix
internationaux et le premier titre de
champion d'europe donc
[Applaudissements]
on savait qu'on l'a devez cette victoire
en partie à ce nouvel allié à monsieur
doute et moi j'étais prête évidemment à
partager cette médaille avec lui mais
quand même pas au point leur trouver des
lendemain matin dans mon lit parce que
la veille on avait un peu fêter ça on le
fait souvent d'un rare on l'a fait donc
quand on l'a fait on la fait bien
j'avais un peu bu pas trop mais en me
réveillant lendemain matin eh ben je
savais pas si tout ça était bien réel
donc j'ai allumé la télévision est comme
ça passe aux informations
j'ai commencé à me détendre et là j'ai
cette petite voiture noire
je pense que vous la connaissez tous qui
m'a dit mais est-ce que tu ne mérites
vraiment ce titre et comment tu vas
faire pour rester à ce niveau là et
comment tu vas faire pour te relancer
donc l'euphorie de la victoire elle
était ultra brève
sauf qu'avec le recul je me dis
heureusement qu'il était là pour me dire
ça heureusement qu'il était là parce que
j'aurais pu péter un plomb et me croire
arrivé et grâce à lui mais j'ai pu
enclencher cette remise en question
qu'on réserve qu'en cas d'échec quand
que dans les cas où ça se passe mal et
grâce à lui je me suis relancé sur la
prochaine grosse échéance de l'année les
championnats du monde les championnats
du monde
ils ont lieu fin mars non je veux pas je
veux pas vous parler ça tout de suite
déjà on va retourner à moscou parce que
forcément rentrer à la maison et on
reprend l'entraînement on se remet à
travailler et là coup de théâtre
vladimir poutine en personne fait passer
le message aux entraîneurs russes les
entraîneurs russes ne doivent plus
travailler pour la concurrence étrangère
ben oui les jeux olympiques ont lieu
dans trois ans à sotchi et la russie
doit briller
donc on comprend qu'on va devoir partir
sauf on sait pas quand ça va prendre
effet on sait par où on va aller
et puis à cette compétition qui arrive
la compétition donc les championnats du
monde sont prévues fin mars 2011 à tokyo
et je pense que vous en souvenez tous
c'est l'année où le tsunami frappent le
japon et fait des milliers de morts en
toute logique la compétition allait
annuler elle sera par la suite reporter
un petite parenthèse nous les sportives
niveau on s'entraîne pour être prêt le
jour j
c'est une énorme galère pour moi en tout
cas l'ag
du temps d'attentes ne pas savoir à
quelle intensité je dois m'entraîner
pour quelle date il faut que je sois
prête
et puis en parallèle
en parallèle on prépare notre notre
départ de moscou et on doit pas en
parler avec notre coach russe
on doit faire tout ça derrière son dos
parce que fillon qu'il faut qu'il
continue à se mobiliser à 100% et
qu'ensemble on puisse décrocher cette
première médaille mondiale
donc je sais pas si vous avez suivi tout
ce micmac mais sur le moment c'était un
énorme bazar et rien ne s'est passé
comme prévu tout a été chamboulé
finalement c'est la russie qui a
récupéré les championnats du monde et
qui a décidé de les organiser à moscou
donc chez nous 1
mais quand j chez nous c'est vraiment
chez nous c'est à dire qu'il ya plus de
30 patinoire dans moscou
et c'est tombé dans la patinoire dans
laquelle on s'entraide au quotidien
alors oui pour la majorité des sportifs
jouent à domicile c'est un énorme
avantage mais pour moi ça signifiait une
seule chose une énorme charge
émotionnelle supplémentaire dans la
patinoire y allait avoir dix quinze
vingt mille spectateurs mais surtout ma
famille d'accueil russe
mes amis et je savais que je devrais
leur dire au revoir quelques heures
après et voilà comment ça s'est passé
[Musique]
comme ça on a besoin de deux programmes
pour avoir un résultat
le premier programme s'est bien déroulé
on est troisième du classement
provisoire
il nous reste quatre minutes et quatre
petites minutes pour faire nos preuves
et enfin décrocher cette médaille
[Musique]
là vous voyez pas mais en fait on n'est
pas deux sur la piste il n'y a pas que
fabian et moi il y en a un qui a décidé
de se taper la creuse de mettre les
patins monsieur doute nous accompagner
[Musique]
profitez bien de cette image parce que
vous la voyez pas souvent c'est très
très rare les double chutant en danse
sur glace
cette seconde là je sais que c'est mort
ces morts comme jamais ça à était mort
c'est irrattrapable
il nous reste deux minutes derrière on
peut patiner comme des dieux on
repartira les mains vides c'est sûr mais
le plus dur c'est pas vraiment la chute
s'est pas vraiment la quatrième place
c'est d'être là en fait vous le raconter
parce que je chante un de revivre le
truc dans le plus dur c'est que déjà il
faut s'excuser auprès des gens qui
comptent la fédération la famille les
amis de cette déception
et puis lendemain matin mais je suis
dans le hall de l'aéroport et j'ai toute
ma vie tu tiens dans une valise et je
dois appeler mon côté et je dois lui
dire merci pour tout et j'ai même pas
cette médaille pour finaliser le
partenariat qu'on a pu avoir pendant
toutes ces années
donc avec mon partenaire et monsieur
doute tous les trois ans en vol pour
detroit détroit la ville fantôme la
ville connue parce que c'était la
première déclarer en faillite après le
crash économique
la ville aussi très connu parce que
c'est le plus fort taux de criminalité
des états unis donc évidemment on n'y va
pas pour des raisons touristiques à on y
va pour rejoindre un centre
d'entraînement un très grand centre
d'entraînement et là bas je suis pas
bien je suis pas bien ce que j'ai
l'impression de subir
je sais qu'il faut que je reconstruise
tout que je me réapproprie un nouvel
environnement des nouvelles méthodes de
travail des nouvelles habitudes de vie
et j'ai se doute qu'ils me lâchent pas
qui est là en permanence à mes côtés et
j'essaie pourtant de m'en débarrasser
entre deux entraînements avec mes petits
patins aux pieds ma petite jupette et je
veux m'asseoir sur un sur un trottoir de
la du parking la patinoire de la
banlieue de détroit et puis un jour j'en
ai eu marre je me suis dit on va en
profiter pour avoir la conversation mais
je lui dis un truc comme ça mais en fait
t'es pas un pote en fait tu joues pas du
tout dans mon camp moi j'ai cru que
j'étais là pour m'aider comme tu as pu
le faire auparavant
mais en fait j'étais prêt pour un autre
avec tes envies de paillettes et envies
de lumière habitude croix ou ta place en
compétition elle n'est pas à mes côtés
elle et pas sur la glace
elle est au fond de mon sac dans le
vestiaire alors maintenant va tout
reprendre à zéro
je vais donner des nouvelles bases je
vais te donner un cadre je vais te
donner des timings et des règles et tu
va les respecter et ça va bien se passer
premièrement plus l'échéance approche et
moins je vais avoir besoin de toi
donc tu vas devenir de plus en plus
petits jusqu'à disparaître ensuite
pendant les phases de création de
changement de remise en question que ce
soit après un échec ou bien après une
victoire
je vais avoir besoin de toi sois présent
et puis quand on a le temps quand
l'enjeu il est faible
tu peux venir me voir on peut discuter
ça peut même être sympathique mais en
tout cas à partir de maintenant on va
former une équipe toi et moi sauf que
c'est moi qui ai mal la danse c'est pas
toi tac bon la suite de ma carrière n'a
pas été pour autant tout rose ça serait
pas drôle et puis ça serait moins riche
en émotions donc il ya eu des hauts des
bas des victoires des blessures mais
j'ai appris à vivre avec monsieur doute
à mes côtés et j'ai appris surtout à
utiliser ses forces et quand on se
pointe aux jeux olympiques de sotchi en
eh ben on a mis toutes les chances de
notre côté et sur la glace on donne le
meilleur de nous et on finit avec la
fameuse médaille en chocolat
c'est à dire 4e et non on ne s'habitue
jamais à cette place là le soir je suis
dévasté je suis furieux suis très en
colère je suis déçu je suis triste je
suis effondré je suis accablé les mots
me manquent c'était et c'était une
horreur c'était très négatif mais ça a
duré une seule soirée
parce que le lendemain matin je sais
qu'il est une nouvelle vie qui va
commencer pour moi une vie dans laquelle
déjà je vais pouvoir vivre en france je
pouvoir rentrer chez moi je pouvoir
passer noël en famille je peux apprendre
des médicaments me pour me soigner sans
être positive aux contrôles de dopage
je vais pouvoir truc de dingue allait au
restaurant à mardi soir avec mes potes
si ça me chante parce que j'ai pas
l'entraînement à 6h du mat le lendemain
je pouvoir faire des sports à risque
et surtout je vais pouvoir arrêter
d'être autocentré comme on l'est quand
on est sportif de haut niveau alors par
ambition a naturellement par par
narcissisme encore que l'un n'empêche
pas l'autre mais c'est toujours mais
heureusement mes compétitions mon régime
alimentaire ça peut être un peu fatigant
et ce premier matin du reste de ma vie
c'est monsieur doute qui à côté moi et
je suis heureuse de le voir je suis
heureuse qu'il soit là qui
m'accompagnent il a décroché d'ailleurs
depuis un cdi à temps plein on se quitte
plus on forme une équipe
c'est pour cette raison que je vous
invite tous à sortir votre monsieur
doute du placard regardez la tête qu'il
a regardé sa façon de s'exprimer de
prendre le pouvoir aussi parfois
et dites vous que c'est normal on a tous
eu droit de douter ça peut être
inquiétant c'est un peu comme des
turbulences en avion c'est flippant mais
on les traverse essayer d'apprivoiser ce
drôle de petit animal soyez à l'écouté
de vos doutes
et puis vous les verrez les bénéfices
les fameux bénéfice du doute
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]